from the start this was a meeting of
friends a display of warmth of
solidarity
in Poland president zielinski was
treated to a hero's welcome as he
visited his closest neighbor
his counterpart gave him the full red
carpet treatment
the troops greeted him as a respected
leader
and outside some of the million
Ukrainian refugees given Shelter by
Poland were among fans hoping to get a
glimpse of him
I'm very excited honestly my heart is
bitter right now I I want to see him I
want to see him at least like from from
the distance I think he's a really
superhero like nowadays superhero like
he's amazing man
the Polish president clearly shared
their sentiment presenting one of
Poland's highest Awards to zelenski who
in return was deeply thankful
I want to thank you for the fact that
you our powerful neighbors did not and
do not allow us to break for the fact
that you help us if Ukraine Falls we
know that Russia will not stop there and
will go further
and there is a lot to be grateful for a
few hours away in the Polish Countryside
Ukrainian troops were being trained to
use leopard two tanks
Poland's Been instrumental in helping to
secure weapons and aid for Ukraine
a small price according to president
Duda for the sacrifices being made
across the border
no one expected Ukraine would stand for
so long the Defenders of Ukraine would
be so heroic
The Defenders are heroic because the
president turned out to be a right
deals were also done to supply more
weapons in the future and build a
lasting relationship
this trip isn't just about reaffirming
friendship it's also about building
credit for the future the longer the war
goes on the more it affects people
living in neighboring countries like
this and Ukraine knows it has to keep
the public on side to ensure support
going forward
for now that isn't a problem zelenski
has stolen the hearts of many in this
nation Siobhan Robbins Sky News Poland